finalmente sucederá lo inédito los
juegos olímpicos se celebrarán a puerta
cerrada en tokio y en las prefecturas
vecinas en marzo ya se había prohibido
la entrada de espectadores extranjeros y
este jueves se conoció la nueva decisión
a cinco bandas consecuencia del cuarto
decreto de estado de emergencia
sanitaria que entrará en vigor en la
capital japonesa el 12 de julio y durará
hasta el 22 de agosto en judo o con aim
hasta mayo si hay ping siguiendo la
decisión del gobierno de extender el
estado de emergencia en tokio el comité
olímpico internacional del comité
paralímpico internacional tokio 2020 el
gobierno metropolitano de tokio y el
gobierno japonés han acordado no contar
con los espectadores en las
competiciones en tokio y discutiremos
con las autoridades locales sobre las
que no tienen lugar en zonas afectadas
por el estado de emergencia
en las últimas semanas tokio registró un
repunte de contagios debido sobre todo a
la variante delta ya que poco más del
15% de la población está totalmente
vacunado como clínica número de
pacientes de entre 40 y 50 años
hospitalizados y con síntomas graves ha
aumentado drásticamente en los últimos
dos meses así que tenemos que actuar
creemos que si no hacemos nada hay altas
posibilidades de que los contagios se
expandan todavía más y llevemos el
sistema sanitario al límite según las
autoridades niponas los 15.000 atletas
serán testados a diario y su movilidad
será limitada para intentar evitar el
contacto con la población precisamente
el temor de que los deportistas
extranjeros se expandan más el virus fue
el principal motivo por el que el 80% de
los japoneses se declaró en contra de la
celebración de los juegos en las fechas
previstas según reveló en mayo el
periódico local asahi shimbún